in a busy corner of North London they've
already demolished two hotels
900 rooms and excavated 20,000 bodies
from a burial ground work on the
high-speed rail link has been going on
for two years at this site but its
future still hangs in the balance
Construction has also started in
Birmingham and the Conservative mayor
for the West Midlands is one of the most
energetic voices in favour at the rail
link we've just emerged from the sort of
paralysis of Briggs that we want to be
that global Britain companies have
invested hundreds of millions pounds if
not billions of pounds on the back of
the HS - decision already taken in 2015
are we really going to go back on our
word when I interviewed Boris Johnson
before the last election he said that
infrastructure was the most radical
policy initiative that he had do you
think this is an example of that I do I
think it is the example of
infrastructure investment actually
driving an improvement in opportunities
job opportunities critically in the
cities of the Midlands in the North now
we know the politics of this are really
clear he was elected by breaching the
red wall in the Midlands in the north
six more seats just in my part the West
Midlands people want to see investment
face one of the route will run between
London to Birmingham with phase two
linking Crewe Manchester and Leeds but
critics claim the project doesn't do
enough to help commuters in the north of
England I think it's the wrong project
and a very expensive project for trying
to achieve the connection between the
north and the Midlands and the south but
the real problem I have is that it
doesn't solve the biggest problem of a
lot which is the appalling commuter
services around Manchester Leeds
Birmingham Nottingham which people rely
on every day and it does nothing to help
that a final decision on whether to go
ahead with HST is expected to be
announced next week but much of the
parliamentary opposition comes from
Boris Johnson's own side and my view the
decision is clear the project has been
flawed from the beginning it was put
forward on vanity grounds frankly the
economics didn't add up
and of course it's put forward on costs
of 35 billion and it's going to be at
least three
times that nice now we need to invest in
infrastructure just not this vanity
project we should cancel it and spend
the money elsewhere there are clearly
and many conservative MPs who are uneasy
about hs2 how big and scaled you think
any rebellion could be in Parliament
it's hard to see where there's scope for
everybody I don't think that anybody's
going to vote against the budget or
something like that but what you're
going to find is a large number of
northern the Midlands MPs actually the
new MPs
a large number of them saying this is a
waste of money how can we justify this
and it won't make them confident in
their government's decision so that's a
bad start that's why this will be a bad
to see how many how many are we talking
about here what can you give us a bit of
an idea of numbers I've never done a
count or what I can tell you is that the
majority of the new MPs I've talked to
are against it and many of the older
backbenchers who's whose judgment in
financial matters I trust well actually
all of them are against it so you're
talking certainly dozens possibly a lot
more than that I think more than half
the bay pages this is exactly the kind
of big-ticket infrastructure project
that appeals to the Prime Minister
giving them chance to put on his
high-vis and promised to get Britain
moving hs2 will put him on a collision
course with dozens of his own MPs back
in Westminster but with a majority of 80
Boris Johnson might not care cornered by
ten year old Boris Johnson gave his
biggest hint yet that hs2 will go ahead
we're in a hole we're in a mess and we
need a way forward so we're thinking
about how to just sort it out that I'm
so with you as Prime Minister I'm sure
you'll get out of the deep hole is it
deep hole is it a small one it's it's a
in a hole size of HS - the only thing to
do is keep digging after years of
uncertainty it seems the diggers will
keep moving but the Prime Minister will
hope he doesn't end up stuck in a
political home